what does an expedition leave behind for
future generations well in the very old
days it wasn't really excavating it was
plunder and grabbed the treasures and go
fill your museums thankfully times have
changed and by about 1900 we had the era
of responsible scientific modern
archaeology underway what does that mean
that means documentation you're trying
to keep a record of everything you do so
that future generations can virtually
reconstruct the results of your
excavation they can test your theories
your interpretations and they can look
at the records of your material and see
if it all makes sense
George Reisner is one of the very first
to do this following in the footsteps of
his British counterpart Flinders Petrie
who was making sequence records and
notations and taking photographs Reisner
took all this a step further and he
worked out a very complex recording
system that tried to capture all the
information relevant to the expeditions
that he directed for so many years so
that began with photography and in those
days it was glass plate negatives think
of lugging a heavy wooden tripod and a
large format camera around these
negatives range in size from four by
five inches fairly small all the way up
to 8 by 10 inches imagine trying to keep
that from breaking
not to mention deal with all the
chemicals and get the things stabilized
when you're out in the dig field with
the sand and the wind all those other
challenges so here is a photograph of
the three different sizes of glass plate
negative that George Reisner used in all
of his digging years so about 40 years
at 23 different archaeological sites he
amassed an archive of about 45,000 of
these plates for Giza
there are about 21,000 of them and I'll
return to that issue in a moment what to
do with these how to make them
accessible so photographs are one
challenge and here is a shot of one of
these large plate cameras this is down
in the tomb of Queen Hedda Paris to
jeez 7,000 X we're about 90 feet
underground so imagine getting all that
equipment down there and the cables and
the electric lights and setting up all
the glass plates here is a photograph of
the storage cabinets of some of these
tens of thousands of images it is time
that they're all made accessible and
that's part of what a project that I was
very fortunate to set in motion is
trying to do this began in the year 2000
with support from the Andrew W mellon
Foundation in addition to photographs of
course you need record books
Ledger's these were the databases of
their time of course reisender didn't
have access to modern SQL databases and
other types of relational information so
it all had to be written in Ledger's
there were photographic register books
they kept the numbers of the negatives
they kept the descriptions of the sights
what angle they were looking at what was
the date who was the photographer and
the same thing happened to the
photographic object records of objects
as well one of the challenges in
preserving this material is that the
documentation is suffering sometimes
almost as much as the antiquities
themselves it has now been about a
hundred years or more
since some of these great expeditions so
you're looking at two photographs of
Giza and they almost look like nuclear
explosions here but what you're really
seeing is the chemical decomposition of
the chemical surface on the glass plates
they need to be conserved this arrow is
now pointing to a photograph of the
famous pear statue of men Caray and his
queen maybe you can just make out the
shadow there as it comes into view in
addition to the glass plates and the
photographic register there were object
register books these were huge Ledger's
that again were the databases for all
the objects found everything inside had
to be recorded precisely and Reisner
worked out a numbering system here's a
sample page of a headrest this would be
a sort of ancient pillow so this object
would get its own number it would get a
description a sketch the measurements
where did it come from that's
all-important the provenance right
what shaft what tomb what number did it
come from
and then of course everything had to be
described
so the
were daily excavation Diaries here is a
page in reissner's own hand and the way
he arranged it was to have a sort of
table of contents at the beginning of
the page and then go into detail we did
this tomb that tomb the shaft that
temple and to describe what was found
how far down they went and what they
might have found these are indispensable
records of the daily progress of the
expedition
not to mention lots of local color
visiting dignitaries and others who
might have come by the site political
events some of the stormy international
events that happened remember this is a
man digging through two world wars one
and two and trying to deal with his
archaeological legacy accordingly in
recent years we made an additional
discovery and that was by contacting the
descendants of George reissner's
Egyptian workmen and it turned out they
had saved about 70 for excavation
diaries that their family members had
been keeping in Arabic for George
Reisner for some reason they had stayed
in Egypt and so we were able to get the
permission to take these volumes and to
scan them and in the case of the Giza
books we've translated them and they
will be part of our corpus of
information these are fantastic records
that join our English Diaries and in
many cases they contain sketches that
are missing from their English
counterparts in addition an expedition
has to leave plans and sections
architectural drawings renderings here
is a shot of a major part of the western
cemetery and you can see the mastaba
tombs large and small all of their
individual shafts have been given letter
numbers and you can see just how
detailed and complex it is to excavate
an area as densely settled as this part
of giza is there are plans and maps that
are in excellent condition depending on
the types of paper used there are others
that are suffering this is a kind of a
cardboard like paper of a very very
large overview plan that really wants to
start crumbling to the touch so we've
got the full range of conditions and
preservation challenges from the
original expedition archive George
Reisner published a tremendous amount
from his work for the Harvard University
Boston Museum of Fine Arts expedition
but he was mostly interested in
interpretation and synthesis so his
volumes are often too
talking about casing types and burial
shafts and development of these
different forms rather than treating
each individual mastaba tomb by itself
completely he wanted to undertake such a
series but he did not live long enough
to do so so it would left to his
successors the curators at the Museum of
Fine Arts Boston to start something
called the Giza mastaba series and to
date there are eight volumes in this
series and they undertake the individual
study of tombs in a one by one sort of
format as much as George Reisner
published he left thousands of pages of
unpublished manuscripts and this is
something else that we've been dealing
with as we try to learn more about Giza
and unite all these different types of
materials and that's really the
challenge how to unite this diverse
media here is a plan and a section
drawing of an individual burial shaft
there are thousands of these left behind
from the graph paper or pencil versions
to the final inked versions meant for
publication and of course figural
drawings of the tomb scenes and
inscriptions many of these have been
drawn too and they all need it to be
taken into account there is a scanning
procedure of one of these oversized and
rather fragile drawings so our big
challenge then in attacking this
material is first of all to be grateful
that it exists because we have this
record of so much work at Giza but then
secondly how do you make it accessible
in the old days even if you had a travel
grant to come to bus and to look at this
archive you would be overwhelmed and
chances are you didn't have enough money
to stay long enough to view everything
that you wanted to view and so the
challenge was to digitize to scan to
type to database all this material and
most importantly to link it together
intelligently so that online users
anywhere in the world could be
interested in just about any part of
Giza from an inscription to a statue to
a potsherd to a tomb number to a
particular photograph taken on a certain
day and all of that material should be
accessible this diagram shows you a
mastaba tomb
that's the individual tomb for an Old
Kingdom elite Egyptian in the center and
then the arrows point to all the
different types of media that we've been
dealing with since the year 2000
since the giza project began first at
the Museum of Fine Arts Boston and now
at Harvard University
so that means photographs old and new
black and white in color diary entries
object register book entries plans and
sections published articles and books
unpublished manuscripts all of it comes
together in all of it gets linked to the
appropriate tombs and monuments in
question along the way we try to work
with newer technologies as well and in
another section I'll be talking about
the 3d applications to Giza from these
traditional archaeological materials
we've then moved into 3d visualization
of the entire site and the goal now is
to merge all of that material old and
new so that you could virtually fly over
the site dive down a burial shaft
inspect a particular wall and click on
it to see a translation or a drawing or
a link to a publication about it so this
drawing that you're seeing now is of a
so-called slab Stila kind of a tombstone
that was put on the outside wall of a
mastaba tomb it shows the deceased tomb
owner her name her titles and it has
various offerings and lists of linen
intended for her burial this was done
without any pen or ink involved at all
but with a process I call digital
epigraphy the old days consisted of
tracing here you see an Egyptologist
with tracing paper actually pencil
tracing the inscription on a Giza tomb
wall we don't work that way nowadays we
work from enlarged photographs and try
to trace the photographs and then we've
taken that step one bit further to move
into the digital realm and that means
high-resolution images on screen that we
then trace with digitizing tablets and
digital pens so here's a beautiful
photograph from the Reisner expedition
again preserving so much more than you
might see on the tomb wall today we then
trace that on screen and create a
beautiful vector line drawing with
wonderful mathematically calculated
lines not pixels or bitmaps and then we
make the photograph go away the result
is a line drawing that can be scaled or
resized or published or colorized or
texture mapped onto a 3d model we can
even pull out individual hieroglyphs and
make paleo
graphical charts to study how the shapes
of the forms changed from tomb to tomb
and over time as the old kingdom
progressed so the Giza project is
blending the older traditional
archaeological material with newer
technologies and in another module I
will show you some of the directions
that were taking all of this exciting
material further
you